بالامس سمع البريطانيون صوت ملكهم الجديد
عبر محطات قطار البلاد تشارلز الثالث يقول
لهم احذروا من الفجوه فهنا رصيف القطار
وعرباته
الملك الجديد يلبس التاج بعد اشهر عندما
رحيل الوالده الملكه اليزابيث الابتسامه
لا تفارقه بجانب الملكه كاملا التي ظهرت
بثوب الملكه متغلبه على كل ما قيل فيما
سبق
ايضا بين الحضور كان للصفوف حكايتها مع
الاقرب لقلب الملك الجديد حيث جلس الامير
ويليام وزوجته كيت ميدلتون في الصف الاول
قريبين من الملك بينما كان
منبوذ العائله طبعا هو هاري بعيدا عن
المقدمه وقريبا من الاضواء حيث ينظر اليه
العالم اجمع بعين باحثه عن مصير الامير
الذي خرج عن العائله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات